[scatting]
[scattered applause]
- AND NOW,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THE MAN YOU'VE BEEN WAITING FOR,
MR. MICHAEL WINSLOW!
- GO GET 'EM, WINSLOW.
[cheers and applause]
BRING THE NOISE!
BRING THE NOISE.
ANOTHER SOLD-OUT NIGHT
WITH THE KINGS OF MOUTH NOISE.
I TELL YOU THOUGH,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS AUDIENCE
WITHOUT WINSLOW.
LUCKY FOR YOU, HUH?
THOSE POLICE ACADEMY FANS.
LOOK AT ALL THE T-SHIRTS.
SIX SEQUELS.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
EVERY SOUND EFFECT
THIS GUY MAKES
IS LIKE A LITTLE, TINY MONA LISA
POPPING OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD HIM DO
THE WALKING
THROUGH THE LEAVES
IN THE FALL
WHILE EATING AN APPLE--
[applause]
- [takes a deep breath]
[grunts]
[imitates squishing]
[imitates wiping]
[imitates squishing, wiping]
[imitates drinking]
[gulp]
- [scatting]
- [imitates wiping]
- [imitates whirring]
- [imitates whip]
- [squeals]
[scatting]
WHEW!
[vocalizing dramatic music]
- SHING.
TING, TING, TING.
- [continues vocalizing]
- TING, TING, TING.
- [vocalizing]
- SHING!
[clicking]
- WHAP!
- [imitates wobbling]
PA-CHHH!
- [vocalizing]
- CHH!
[imitates swiping, gibbering]
- [imitates swiping]
- [gibbering]
- [imitates gun clicking,
gunshot]
[blows]
- [panting]
- [imitates heartbeat]
[imitating beeping]
- [scatting]
- [imitating beeping]
[imitates flat line]
[imitating sirens]